That would be best for uric acid in the soil or heel of your foot.
So uric acid is an issue that causes gout and gouty arthritis.
Uric acid is usually excreted by the kidneys.
So supporting kidney function is good and decreasing diet.
You can google search.
I don't remember everything, but things that will increase uric acid, foods that will increase
uric acid.
A beer is one.
Some alcohol can be another one.
And then there's some common things that we've used for people with increased uric acid,
which would be cherry juice.
There's concentrated cherry supplements out there that pubic granite juice could be helpful.
And then if that's the biggest thing, and then looking at lymph flow, so helping support
lymph flow so that it's not suddenly new to your lower extremities, you're able to get
it back to the kidneys and excrete it.
And again, support kidney function.